very uh very flattered to be able to
call this guy a friend because on paper
guys like this don't like guys like me
but somehow we've been able to work it
out and been great friends over the
years and he's a friend of yours too tj
shane powers
joins the show who i say is los
angeles's only tampa bay buccaneers fan
i know there are more people in la with
bucks jerseys on as of late but shane
powers walk me back to your earliest
memories of being a buccaneers fan in
los angeles and what that was like yo
first of all morning morning and
i'm having a really cool moment because
tj's there you're there
rich is on vacation he got it somewhere
i'm so happy and he's got a great people
picker man
he's got the right guys uh in the in the
in the spot right now all right how
my first bucks moment 1979.
my mom
is working hard on the railroad
where she's a single mother we don't
have a ton of loot
my christmas present
my big christmas present was a sports
illustrated subscription
first it was for my birthday christmas
november-ish and the first issue i ever
got was dewey and leroy selman sacking
a quarterback and it was when the bucks
had gone on 26 over the first two years
and then their third year they came out
7-0 and nobody could believe it and so
they were the big story and i just
remember seeing that and going that's my
squad because in nebraska we you know
there isn't really any
oxygen for a pro football team in
nebraska because of the
cornhuskers obsession and so i didn't
have any regional i guess i had the
chiefs or
i might have had chicago but i just i
was like that's my squad and it was
at first very painful
and it's also been amazing because 40
years later my son who's 28 and grew up
in la is a big buccaneers fan it's the
only thing i made him uh
him hit the champion the huskers
and so we've had this really wonderful
journey it's he's having fun now because
i mean let me ask you guys a question
rich and tj
and anybody else in that building
and i don't want to say it i don't want
to say it out loud
but is this potentially
a year
when a pro football team
could end up doing something
that only one other pro football team
has ever done on paper with the 22 that
we got back
is that a possibility yes
whoa del tufo right yes
100
brockman you had some feeling about this
right that's just a flat snap yes a
hundred percent
well shane is brockman here as you as
you know going undefeated is is next to
impossible it's only happened once the
page i can't say that word you can but i
can't but yeah it's next to impossible i
said it's hap it's happened once the
patriots almost did it they were a you
know helmet away from doing it yeah they
were rodney harrison that guy so
i mean i'm not going to say it's not po
i think it is possible i think the bucks
are absolutely stacked like you said all
22 super bowl starters are back tom
brady is just like a vampire like it's
unbelievable i i i there's no reason to
think that
it's going to happen but there's no
reason to think it's not going to happen
like i can't believe this is even in
your world shane as a buccaneers fan for
life can you believe the fact that we're
sitting here in august and even debating
this like seriously it's it's really
bizarre and you know you you
if you're not from new england you have
sort of a wild hatred for breed just
because it's not fun
i mean you guys are so good but then he
comes here he comes to tampa and you get
behind it and then you are a part of his
whole thing
and he's truly the goat i mean he it's
ridiculous and i just if we're talking
about goat stories
could you imagine this guy winning his
eighth ring and doing the other thing
i mean that would have to be the that
would have to be it for him would it not
would that walk him into the sunset no
he's gonna play forever i'm convinced i
think he's gonna play deep into his 50s
at this point i don't want to see why if
tom brady wins the super bowl this year
they should like physically remove him
like there's nothing left for you to do
tom we are not like he's no longer
allowed to play football that's it
you're done that's it like your contract
is ripped up it's set on fire thank you
for playing
russell simmons not gonna quit he's not
gonna quit they have to make him stop
that's it well ben and i were talking
about this about playing golf yesterday
like brady is one of those guys you see
all the second careers from all these
people like brady doesn't know anything
other than playing football i think he
would just be super bored without it yep
yeah shane do you see him opening packs
on crackpot breakers what's brady gonna
do after
i mean crackpot breaks ben get it right
now breaks yeah dj tj joins us on the
break it is so fun we pulled some crazy
cards last night it was a it was a blast
anybody that ever wants to break cards
come through because we uh we talk we
have fun in the meantime the thing about
brady is this and this is the only weird
thing
i have first of all he's very he's very
aware i would imagine of his branding
and his marketing and if you're telling
a story about the goat to leave with
your eighth ring as you've done the one
thing that no other team has done since
the early 70s in a in a season where
they're adding a game
i just feel like maybe that could be the
thing that sends him off other than that
there is a
how about this i don't know if i don't
know as grown men i know that you guys
have all on some level proven yourself
to yourself right and there's a hole in
it
there's got there's something still in
brady that drives him to do this that i
don't think is entirely healthy
it's it's what these what does brady
gotta do
to prove himself to himself to get on
with something else
like i've got seven rings i've got this
beautiful kids i got a wife like
i'm 45.
what is it thing that drives him i think
the thing that drives him and no
disrespect to this guy but there's a
thing
in him
that hasn't been quenched because it's
impossible to do what he's doing without
some kind of weird
whole or issue i mean you think about
all of the greats like romo unbelievable
talent great leader but the guy has like
got a great life in a good way and white
me plays golf but he doesn't seem to
have that hole and that's i think the
biggest reason why he couldn't get over
but you look at other guys
that are great they
they have some kind of thing inside of
them that they've got to fix
and i
how is brady still
have you ever done anything that good
for that long get bored or you're like i
want to go try and do something
something else
shane i've been on this show for three
weeks i've loved it but i'm very excited
for next week it's gonna be a new set of
challenges and a new opportunity the
idea of brady still doing it like you
said you know reinvention the path to
self-discovery something you know very
well when you look at all the different
lives you've lived and challenges you've
taken on in your in yourself and in your
career and your life it's led you to
this moment he's back at another
training camp back at another film
session the grind is is just
relentless with him good he could just
love the game and love being tom brady
and he could be afraid of what tom brady
means after he no longer does
what he's the greatest of all time at
doing so i
i don't know it would be wonderful to
sit down and have a conversation with
that guy and ask him
yo are you good with your dad
are you good with your mom like what is
going on that drives to that's
because i don't know what else this
guy's got to do
to prove himself to himself anyway i
don't mean it's not always an unhealthy
obsession for sure and to be honest he's
probably not going to have to do too
much in order for that undefeated season
to happen because their defense is
loaded as somebody who knows this team
loves the tampa bay buccaneers what do
you love about their defense in
particular and especially their
linebacking core
well i think their biggest their biggest
win is levante david now he is the most
underrated linebacker potentially of all
time
and he anchors that defense and so when
you've got a guy that good anchoring the
middle it allows shaq bear it'll and
especially devin white the the young
young buck i mean all that dude really
has to be responsible for on that
defense is being fast
and getting to the ball and making plays
because he's got
he's got the he's he's got levante david
kind of running and backing up and being
the anchor of that whole team so i mean
i don't i literally i i
have thought about all of the different
scenarios levante david anchoring that
defense you've got shaq barrett who's
sort of
like maturing a little bit and then
you've got this kid who just can run
around and make plays
it's
have you seen their schedule do you guys
i'm sure you guys somebody's got a
schedule in front of them is what is the
potential
hang up game
in that season if we're talking about
the the the u word obviously shane week
one against the dallas cowboys is gonna
be yeah you know that's the first thing
they gotta worry about so
you know tj how do you feel about your
team
look man as as a dallas cowboys fan you
know every every year and i say this to
these guys if you're a fan of a team
every year you pretty much have to go in
thinking you're going to win the super
bowl right but regardless if you
realistically have a chance or not or
why else go through all the pain that
you have to endure as a football fan
shane can you imagine tj super bowl week
here in los angeles if the cowboys make
it to sophie it would be so obnoxious no
it would be it would be another sort of
whack-a-doo
sure but they're not making it
this guy saying we're both real trouble
i mean they got they're not ready
they're they're not built back up on
defense i'm not a huge i'm not all the
way in on dak
uh i think zeke zeke's performance is
directly connected to dak
so if dak doesn't do well i don't think
you know zeke's one of those really odd
strange
wonderful type football players i mean
he is he is unbelievably good but he's
got a little bit of that ricky williams
like there's more to this
than football thing going on and i think
he's i think he's can i think his
performance is how about let me ask you
a question because i
i've got i've been have been in a
dynasty keeper league for 30 years and
we went to a straight keeper in 2000 so
all we do is draft rookies right
my son made a big move he traded away a
number one round pit a first rounder and
a second rounder because he's all the
way in on cd lamb
i want to know what you think about cd
lamb jeff i
i think i think boston made the right
move there shane i'm all in on cd lamb i
feel like
you know i obviously i think amari
cooper is the the wide receiver one on
the cowboys but i think that is probably
going to change by the end of this
season
cd is looking
like he is the next big thing and i mean
i don't know if that's my cowboy fandom
coming through that's just might be
right a little bit about it yeah if it's
just my football
fandom but i
man i
i'm all in on cd land bro i really am
shane powers joins the show former
survivor on cbs worked in nightlife has
a radio show and podcasts in the 30-year
keeper league now he's open up packs
every night on crackpot breaks
credible reinvention to self-discovery
let's go back to the beginning though
we've talked a lot this week shane about
which nfl reporters which nba reporters
would do well on a show like survivor
who could live off the land would sal
palantonio be someone that you would
want to build an alliance with
that written segway was incredible you
delivered that with intense intense
passion i would say that sao paulo
antonio
would be a jury guy
he would get to the jury i don't think
he has
i don't think he's got the moxie to win
the game now that doesn't mean that he's
not going to have i i it doesn't mean
that he's not going to do well he's just
not going to win i mean
you fire off some names and i'll let you
know how do you think jane slater does
for the nfl network i mean i i don't
even know who that is you gotta you
gotta move on i have no disrespect to
james slater who's james slater jane
slater works for nfl network covers the
cowboys she was very passionate about
her odds of hunting for food she thinks
she's very resourceful uh who else is on
the list brock lesnar i think mina kimes
i could go all the way shane
you like her i don't listen again i
don't know enough about who was the who
was the who is the young woman that the
hosts the morning nfl football show okay
adams kay adams
i think she would do really really well
i think she would do incredibly well i
think she's
she's incredibly bright
she you know you know you ever you ever
hang out with and again i'm not trying
to be sexist or misogynist but you ever
hang out with there are times when
you're hanging out with women and they
want to bond with you as a man and they
over
they start over analyzing or over
starting giving you over statistics
about football and stuff and it's really
it's adorable but it can be annoying she
doesn't seem or doesn't when i listen to
her talk about sports i truly believe
what she's talking about so i i for me i
think that she would do i think she
would do unbelievably well she also
manages those three personalities
really well which is important when
you're trying to play
survivor because she's sort of the
quarterback of that whole thing and i
don't believe those three dudes think
that that's going on but she's
she's the anchor to that whole thing
yeah absolutely let's go to the more
classic you could lose any of those
other dudes you can't lose her on that
show right let's go to the host then
like how do you how would you rate rich
and dan patrick on survivor
this would be this would be amazing i
mean
i don't
dan when i you know when i was growing
up i think dan would have been a real
real
he would have been a real uh uh chance
to win it the pride he's he's gotten a
little curmudgeony in his old age
and there's a little bit of a
curmudgeony element that does not play
on survivor at all now he's he's out of
this he's got enough he's super charming
so a little bit if he if he can if he
can stay in the charming lane with the
sort of curmudgeony older guy
he might have a shot but i would say his
chances were way better 20 years ago
than they are now also dan's got himself
a real life like he's he's all the way
set up and so when you when that's the
other element you guys don't understand
you put dan patrick on an island with no
food and no water and he's like yeah no
that's not what's going on i mean
[Laughter]
that's not how i live my life anymore so
rich would have a better shot than dan
but when they were both in their prime i
believe dan has a better shot than rich
i believe there was a little bit of a
when rich was young and coming up there
was a little there was an excitement to
him that was infectious but i think also
that that excitement
could have been annoying especially if
you haven't eaten in 15 days
like a real go-getter over-excited in
life kind of guy you're like bro you got
to take that elsewhere
i had a shower in three weeks dude i am
not trying to be overshadowed but
nothing right now yeah you haven't
bathed in three weeks you don't want to
talk about archery highlights from the
olympics i totally get it uh who would
be the favorite then shane we'll leave
with this one who's the favorite for nfl
reporter survivor
it's interesting you know you don't you
didn't bring up steven a because he
would be out like in the first three
right he's too much
you didn't bring up like guys like al
michaels like al michaels in his prime
would have walked into a ring i mean
there's there's no he's the full money
he's the complete guy he's charming he
knows when the way back he knows when to
take uh he knows when to take initiative
like al michaels would have been of all
of the people that i know of in the
sports announcing thing
al michaels would have been the easiest
lock to win survivor what about costas
there is something about costas i would
imagine if i was sitting with bob
and there were six to go
i gotta believe there's a moment where
i'm like bob's up to something and bob
is smarter than me
and so we got to take bob out
shane you're the greatest
i hope your buccaneers get back to the
super bowl
i hope
i said you're the greatest i hope your
buccaneers get back to the super bowl
and i hope we vote kostas off the island
i do too
shane powers joining the show and also
ben i've spent shane has taken a few
thousand of my dollars
on this uh crackpot breaks i'm i'm
addicted i've gotten brockman on this
page it's it's jane's been taking my
money for years first it was my
nightclub money then it was my baseball
card money and now it's uh radio money
yeah he's taking all of it so uh we're
having a yeah with the the the the card
breaking i think my son and i are going
to put
our lebron james rookie card up for
auction at golden auction we bought it
like 20 years ago yeah this is a great
story
and we we was like 160 pack we bought
the card him and i both freaked out we
put it in a piece of plastic then it got
lost
like this happens with everybody in
their cards for like a decade he found
it a few years ago then you got to take
it and get it graded you got to hope for
the best we ended up getting a 9 and a
10 on the auto and so it's uh i think
we're just going to put it up in the eye
it's been a really really fun 20-year
thing with that card so you got to root
us in on the auction it's going in soon
awesome man reinvention the path to
self-discovery i love it shane thanks
for taking some time man
of course boys you guys have a really
good day
and i'm sure i'll you'll get about 130
140 bucks out of me this weekend
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here